oh hi everybody are you looking for a
Bing themed movie well your stat Allah
are you looking for a film that heavily
features Google then the world is yours
the internship is hitting theaters Vince
Vaughn Owen Wilson they're added again
we had the opportunity to sit down with
Vince Vaughn since there's so much
Google in the movie we decided to Google
the crap Adam al Rudnick for screen
junkies here with our Vince Vaughn nice
to see you but oh man thanks for having
me great movie love to see you and Owen
back together it's been nice people
really responded well to the film so
it's been a lot of fun since I not the
best interviewer in the world I figured
we can use Google to figure out the best
questions to ask you or you can just ask
me questions whatever whatever you're
comfortable with I don't think you're
the worst interviewer ever what's the
question that would come to mind can you
dunk it would be a two-handed dunk got
an after-school special when I was a kid
where I had to do that you are an
after-school special I was in a couple
after schools oh when they focus on one
I meant actually a person that became my
closest friend Peter Billingsley oh yeah
there's a story that's right we did an
after-school special called the fourth
man Peters character was kind of not a
jock so he thought in order to make the
relay team why not get hopped up on
steroids and then during the relay race
guess who fell down right before the
finish line
Anse Armstrong no oh no Peter
Billingsley Peter Hollings like I had no
idea that you had such a positive
influence on people's lives no you know
what else I have no idea what's gonna
come up if I type is Vince Vaughn is
Vince Vaughn in Jurassic Park do you
want me to ruin it for you
well yeah these are my questions but
don't you think that the answers are in
here I think everything's in there well
you're answering this question for me
it's been fun a nice guy no no I want to
step on some feelings but I'm getting
the opposite I understand um is Vince
Vaughn dead yeah let's look up does does
Vince Vaughn die in Jurassic Park Vince
Vaughn disappears in Jurassic Park
uh-huh and we don't know what happened
to Vince Vaughn a Jurassic Park just
goes if you're talking those errors in
this case yes because we're talking
about this one does Vince Vaughn wear a
hairpiece look
even nice head of hair I do have a nice
head of hair thank you the answer's no
no the answer is no why don't we give
that a tug oh yeah
real deal that's real deal that's right
that's pure Vince that's all vents does
Vince Vaughn have a Twitter I do not do
you have a Twitter I do have a Twitter
let me ask you about this if you don't
mind make it conversational okay you
feel a pressure to come up with
something how consistently Twitter's
like a BM try to do it every day they're
not always gonna be great that's
understood yeah I like it sometimes it's
smooth like what's going on right here
with this interview uh-huh what's next
uh why did Vince Vaughn go to jail I've
been arrested but I haven't really spent
a lot of hard time in the pen as it
would be why did Vince Vaughn leave
Jennifer Aniston well there was no no uh
some things that gonna have to be left
to this machine
why did Vince Ilan get arrested in into
the wild well that was my character and
into the why yes and I believe that
there was things involved cable boxes
yes had you read the book before seeing
the film I hadn't won the compliments of
that movie is that people who like the
book also like the film is there an
authorized version of the internship a
novelized form no there has not yet been
but that that is in the works now let's
talk a little bit about the internship
yes what did you think um I really
enjoyed it the one thing I'd say you you
and Owen seem a lot hipper see it I
don't know if that's true yeah sometimes
the person that can come off the most
hip is maybe the least hip closers the
posers f the poser is Masum hug him hug
him nfm hug him then mm maybe a little
bit of both uh Vince I want to thank you
so much for taking time still good sport
I appreciate it thank you so we're
having a debate at what point in the
interview did I most get on Vince
Vaughn's nerves do you think you spotted
it let us know in the comments below so
we put out a call to action for you to
tell us what's the worst M night
Shyamalan film of all time thousands of
you responded overwhelmingly so here
they are from best Shyamalan to worst
Shyamalan the least hated M night
Shyamalan film of all time
unbreakable followed closely by The
Sixth Sense which I thought everyone had
seen
but apparently I was wrong was the
spoiler from The Sixth Sense really
necessary that guy I was really looking
forward to watching that movie it's been
14 years I mean what are you 14 years
old
in that case send me your birth
certificate following those movies the
village after earth signs lady in the
water the happening which means the most
hated Shyamalan film of all time the
last airbender taking it in a landslide
with sixty nine point six percent your
vitriol for that film was overwhelming
my favorite comment of a bunch Danzig Oh
8 says The Last Airbender more like the
last fart bender Danzig oh wait guess
what you win our t-shirt fart bender we
love the fart comment thanks to
everybody who chimed in about their
least favorite M night Shyamalan film do
you want to win a shirt say something
funny in the comments below thanks for
watching I'm Hal Rudnick bye bye
[Music]